[Music]
recently TBS asked us if we could
develop possibly some more programming
for their network okay they said hey you
know we get along you guys got any ideas
and people really love shows about cakes
reality shows about cakes they do know I
thought hey we should get in on that so
we came up with a cake show all our own
and I think TBS is gonna love it
take a look if any of the urinal cake
boss is all about helping other people
after all it's called a you'll run okay
not a Miren okay no room for selfishness
in this business you know when people
ask me who made me the boss of all those
urinal cakes and I'm like well you know
I didn't look at this paint you're on a
cake in a men's bathroom hey clearly
this year no cake was meant for a
woman's urinal no I think this
generation has really lost its way as
far as a urinal cake knowledge and
appreciation goes and you know sometimes
it's really I'm sorry can we just just
sum up I did not like this urinal cake
guys all right let's do better next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah